So the upshot of address space switching is you have to really ask
the question, are we switching between small
protection domains or large protection domains? If
you are switching between small protection domains,
then by taking advantage of whatever the
hardware gives you, you can make. The
switching between these small protection domains efficient
by careful construction of the services, on the
other hand if the switch is from one
large protection domain to another large protection domain.
The switching cost, the explicit cost of switching
from one hardware address space, to a different
hardware address space Is not that significant, because
the loss of locality when you go from
a large protection domain to another large protection domain,
both in terms of TLB misses that are
going to happen, when you start executing the new
large protection domain. For translations as well as the
cache effects, that the fact that your cache is
now going to be warm with the data
and the instructions for the new protection domain. That
cost is much more significant than just the switching
cost going from one large protection domain to another
large protection domain. So this is the way, the address-based
switching myth, is debunked by the L3 microkernel, by construction.